all right so we're on season 2 of
Riverdale we haven't been on set for
season 1 so we're happy to be here for
season 2 yeah I would just love for you
to tell me what is the experience been
like so far moving on to season two of
the show
Riverdale season one we didn't know
where it was gonna go we didn't know
what the reaction was gonna be we didn't
know if people were gonna like it as
much as we liked it we had no idea
so season two coming back after like
knowing that people liked it and we're
considered you know a success it's a
totally different vibe and it's really
exciting at the same time there's more
pressure to live up to that as well of
course it's become a phenomenon and like
it's huge the show what was that worth
phenomena man are you yeah I just wanted
it phenomenon huge ok good ha it's been
it's incredible I mean obviously you go
into a show hoping that it's gonna be
successful and yeah you know everybody
has reservations even about calling a
show success oh you almost be like come
on jinx they say yeah exactly what but I
mean were you prepared for the magnitude
of success the show would be no I didn't
I mean I don't know how you can prepare
for that because you just you never know
a um I would say it's about time though
I'm very happy that there's a show that
I'm on that that has gotten you know
really good reviews and that people like
it and I think the thing that surprises
me the most is the age range of viewers
just it kind of crosses over any age
range and I really I really like that
cuz to me that's just good storytelling
I think part of that is you know it
deals with real topics there or any age
like how important is dealing with
things like drugs date rape you know
slut-shaming stuff like that do you
think that's been part of the success of
the series yeah it's funny because we
did an episode on on basically date rape
and stuff like that and it timed out
coincidentally with the whole world kind
of exploding in Hollywood with the
Harvey Weinstein's and all of that so it
was really timely but also I really you
know I'm really proud of how the lodges
reacted to it it's not necessarily
within the bounds of the law but as a
parent I completely understand so I was
actually look very proud of the
storyline that we that we tackled
speaking to you guys most of your actors
today on the show you
I seem like such a great cast and a
little bit of a family what's it been
like working with the team on this show
it's been pretty amazing as we all first
of all we all get along really well so
that's really nice and then just sort of
being out here in Vancouver you don't
have any of your regular friends around
so it sort of has forced us to come
together more and because of that it
does it feels like a family I would love
to go a little deep into your character
here I feel like in season one she was a
lot more just can we just say that I'm
sorry yes good she needs an apology
because I feel like in this season she
has just become very self-centered she
couldn't see selves okay well she's
reserving she seems to care a lot about
her husband's return well okay so look
this is my take on Hermione's season 2
versus season 1 season 1 she got to be
the kind of person that she's always
wanted to be without hiram season 2 he's
back so she's had to go back into
survival mode back into business mode
and Veronica who's challenging her
father doesn't have a clue what she's
doing so in my minds her mind he would
rather have Veronica hate her because
it's a lot safer than hating her father
over a mother-daughter relationship as
you know most people's mother-daughter
relationships are you know they're up
and down they are that's completely
normal and natural what's gonna happen
with Veronica and Hermione's
relationship this season where are we
going with this this season I know
Hermione and Veronica's relationship to
me the core of what you saw in season 1
was who they really are and how they
truly feel about each other at the same
time you know Hermione's kind of crossed
a line a lot several times actually but
I really do hope that we get to see
their love for each other again as a
mother and daughter because I really
cherish that well don't get mad at me
but my coworker called Hermione a
villain
this show I've been called snake
serpents I've been called it all yeah
it's either like her - Queen her might
he's a snake back and forth
how's the fan reaction been season two
as have you been getting the snake emoji
I get it's funny because people's
reactions have been different some are
like she's a complete snake I hate her
and other people are like Queen and so
it just kind of depends on what what I
guess your taste is but it's gone back
and forth - both and I don't I don't
mind riding riding both sides why would
you tell although I blame mark all the
time I Thomas Hiram's fault it's his
fault because he came back why would you
tell people that they should tune into
season 2 in the show they should tune
into season 2 because it's it's deeper
more mysterious more dark more romantic
than season one ever was